Hey guys, it's Ryan. Here's the last video in our talk of Biomechanics, and we're going to talk
about duration of force in this one. So we already talked about magnitude of force, how much force
we're applying to the PDL, and we talked about the area over which the force is applied to.
Now we're going to talk about how long that force is applied for. So here's a graph of tooth movement,
efficiency hours in the day, and we need four to eight hours as an absolute minimum
for tooth movement, and then the longer you have an appliance working, especially in terms of like
a removable appliance that you can take in and out at will, the longer you have it acting per day,
the better. And why is this? Because if you remember in our magnitude video, we mentioned that at four
hours for light force at least, that's where cyclic AMP levels are increased, and if we don't have
four hours duration of force, well, we're kind of short-circuiting the system, and we're not getting
those cyclic AMP levels increased, we're not getting cell differentiation for osteoblasts and osteoclasts,
and we're not getting bone resorption in the areas where we need it. Now, if we have force
applying over a certain amount of time, the magnitude of the force typically isn't the same.
Ideally, if we could, that force over time would be steady and unchanging. Now, this is
kind of the case for a super elastic nickel titanium wire that can
phase change and maintain the same consistent force over time and distance, but in this case,
we're kind of talking, let's talk about the standard, you know, stainless steel wire or whatever.
Over time, force is going to tend to decrease because teeth are moving and the wires getting
weaker over time or whatever, the force is decaying for whatever reason. And the closest we can get
to continuous, which is in quotes because it's not perfectly the same level, is getting some
amount of decay and then reactivating it with, you know, tying in a new wire that's bent differently,
and then that starts to decay and then we reactivate and, you know, four to six weeks, we reactivate,
etc. So that's kind of the continuous model for force over time.
For interrupted, that's where we dropped to zero before activating again. So we start somewhere
and then instead of replacing it where we would have with continuous, we let it go down to zero,
then there's no force at all. The wire is completely passive. And then sometime later, we
reactivate, put a new wire in and then let it die out. So that's interrupted, which may seem like
it's less useful than continuous, but there are reasons to have both. And then intermittent is
for patient activated removables. So that's, you know, if you have to wear some sort of appliance
and you take it out when you eat and then put it back in, or you take it out to brush your teeth
and then put it back in, that's basically what's happened. So it's kind of like continuous they're
interrupted, but we're losing force for the time where the appliance is out and then it bounces back
to, you know, where it would have been. And then here, it's just like a reactivation,
putting in a new appliance or strengthening the old one. So that's really just for removables.
But continuous and interrupted, I just want to mention briefly that continuous is best for
something that applies light force as close to continuous as we can get is ideal. However,
we do not want this continuous force model for a heavy force. If it's a heavy continuous force,
then we have a problem because the PDL doesn't have time to repair between the undermining
resorption if we're thinking back to the first talk on magnitude. So if the PDL doesn't have time
to repair, it's going to undergo damage, it's going to be injured, you're going to get unnecessary
pain. So this is a problem for heavy force. What we want for heavy force is actually interrupted.
We want the force to decay after undermining resorption. So we want really one period of
undermining resorption and then decay to zero, stop. And then let the PDL repair itself,
then have the patient come back and then reactivate and then let it die out, then
undermining resorption already happened, let it repair and then reactivate. So this is like
from where I'm starting here, the mouse to about here would be like four weeks, two weeks to
resort, two weeks to repair, and then have the patient come back after that. Yeah, and I think
that's about it. So we talked about magnitude, type of movement and duration, and these three
components contribute to how much force a tooth is experiencing, how much force a PDL is experiencing,
and as such, how much a tooth is going to move in its socket. So I'm going to talk next about
mechanics, how wires and things work, and apply these kind of forces to the tooth so we can link
these two concepts together. Thanks for watching guys, and I'll see you in the next video.